[Applaudissements]
c'était ma première année au liban comme
citoyenne puisque jusque là j'habitais
dubaï
deux mois avant l'arrivée ma mère m'a
demandé d'assurer une liste les
avantages et les inconvénients du retour
aux niveaux ainsi au pays natal qui ne
vous présentez vous manque une belle
destination de vacances ne venaient plus
concret elle m'a encouragé à aider la
communauté de mon village
mais comment pouvais-je le faire en
offrant une somme d'argent
adf qui n'en avaient pas assez pour
s'inscrire à l'école c'était l'argent
que j'avais reçue pour ma première
communion
deux mois plus tard en novembre j'ai
demandé pour mon anniversaire commun de
cadeaux mais puis tout l'argent qui
contribuent au traitement d'un enfant
qui souffrait du cancer
une représentante de chaises
l'organisation à qui j'ai offert le ton
est venu me voir le jour de
l'anniversaire
elle m'a offert elle elle a pris des
photos avec moi elle m'a offert un
certificat me féliciter pour ma
générosité
je vous assure la joie que j'ai ressenti
surpasser tout autre bonheur je me
sentais et voiliers et soudain mon
retour il en avait beaucoup plus de sens
c'est bien un an et depuis je me dis que
ce que j'ai fait me l'universel n'est
pas assez large en haîti la chose la
plus précieuse dans la ville où va
l'argent
comment ils aident les autres j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi pouvoir trouver une
réponse jusqu'au jour j'ai décidé de
donner quelque chose que l'on met quoi
puisque j'adorerais la magie j'ai pensé
préparé des tours de magie à des
personnes du troisième âge
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu le faire
mais je ne me suis pas découragé je
devais trouver autre chose
alors j'ai contacté orange foot place
une organisation qui lutte contre la
faim je me suis à l'ordre retrouvent
retrouvé dans un camp de réfugiés
un vrai bilan viennent dans ce camp il y
avait une
cole ou des enfants de 9,9 y aller pour
la première fois de leur vie
on pouvait aussi voir des moments qui
apprennent à lire et à écrire a été jean
galia à l'école comment peut-il y avoir
des mères nous éduquer comment est ce
possible que l'enfant de 9 ans ne sache
pas à quoi ressemble une chaise ou à
quoi sert une table en voyant le chemin
qui traverse tous les jours praia à
l'école j'ai été choqué je n'étais
quelques escaliers entouré de murs de
briques recouverte éternité le sac de
plastique un chemin plein de désespoir
les pacistes pouces qui l'a alors dans
ma tête mon coeur bat fort le choc
dépassé j'ai été surprise par leur
enthousiasme
un enthousiasme qui remplissait le coeur
des enfants
chaque matin lorsqu il était temps
d'aller à l'école le chemin que je
considérais plein de désespoir
représentait pour eux un chemin plein de
ces critères pl d'intimité et plein
d'espoir j'ai décidé de danser breux et
de la reprendre à danser les voir si
heureux
je me réjouis sortir ces expériences
m'ont appris qu'il en faut peu que
peuvent améliorer la vie les autres la
joie la vraie celle qui dure une
éternité ne vient que de l'action de
dorel donner de son temps et de sa
présence il ya deux ans je me sentais
une héroïne pour avoir faire un tout
matériel mais maintenant je peux dire
que pour être in win il suffit de
rentrer quelqu'un d'autre heureux de
partager ce moment du choix avec lui
maintenant vous retourner dûment a du
sens les gens ont besoin de moi ici et
moi j'ai besoin de m'inscrire
[Applaudissements]